(woosh)
(soft chime)
- I've been doing this for--
- the Shriver lecture
- The Shriver lecture,
which is associated with
an award it's to recognize
someone or a group
in the community, excuse
me, that has contributed
significantly to the lives
of people with disabilities
and to acknowledge their contribution
and to recognize all that they have given
us and so this year it is Susan Mizner
from the ACLU is doing the Shriver lecture
and after that we are going
to a few minute ceremony
to present the award and
then we have wine and cheese.
(laughter)
So please stay put and thank you so much
for being here and for all that you do.
And you are gonna sit here,
I'm gonna sit right here.
- Okay,
and where's the button?
Okay, so my disclosure slide.
I was trying to figure out how to explain
where we are politically to a conference
of health care professionals
and one of my colleagues has talked about
what we are going through
right now as a stress test
for democracy, so this
last year has seen attacks
on muslims, on medicaid, on
immigrants, on trans people,
on the right of women
to control their bodies.
But it's also seen attacks
on what is the core
foundation of our democracy.
It's seen attacks on the courts,
trying to delegitimatize the court,
it's seen attacks on the right to protest
and on our free press.
So after 13 months I think
the good news is that
the patient is holding up pretty well.
Our democracy has been,
solid our courts have pushed
back on the ban of muslims
on DOCA recipients and
resisted so far on encroaching
further on a woman's right to choose.
And our protests and our advocacy
and I say this collectively
not just the ACLU has so far
presented, prevented
medicaid from being gutted
by block grants and has
prevented politicians
and police police from stifling the press.
Most importantly our
populous the lifeblood
of our democracy is more invigorated
and aerobic than ever.
I don't think we've seen
a time with this much
political engagement since the 1960s
when I see some people
who were active back then.
So as I review just a few
of the things going on,
I will pause and in that,
spirit of involvement note
a few ways that you may
be able to participate in pushing back on
some of the civil liberties threats
to people with disabilities.
So Lucy and Jerry asked me to talk about
a few things we couldn't
actually narrow it down
so I'm actually going to do a grand solum
through education and adversive discipline
the school to prison pipeline,
conservatorship and
supported decision-making
and then voting.
- [Lucy] In half an hour.
- In half an an hour yes
(audience laughs), it's gonna,
we're gonna cover it all.
- [Lucy] Go for it.
(laughter)
- Just keepin the stress
on, okay so education
and adversive discipline,
how many of you have heard
about restraint and seclusion?
Good, okay so I don't have
to spend a lot of time
on what it is, it is a pretty significant
use of force generally against students
and experts probably
many of you have already
weighed in on the fact that it, seclusion
and restraint doesn't
have any educational value
and should be used only
in emergency situations.
You probably also know
that it is used extremely
disproportionately on
students with disabilities.
I'll get there, so just a
couple of data points for you.
12% of students in
public schools have IDEA,
so identified as students
with disabilities,
75% of the students who they
use physical restraint on
are those students with disabilities.
Many of you know TASH, which is
a very great advocacy organization.
They have done a film to
explain from the student's
perspective what restraint
and seclusion is like.
And I've done just a few snippets here,
if you want to watch the full video,
and I would encourage you to
it's on stophurtingkids.com.
Pretty easy to remember.
(melancholy music)
- I crawled out of there, she came back
and screamed at me, if
you don't stay in there,
I'm going to strap you in that chair
and lock the door.
- One sat on my leg,
one sat on me other leg,
two sat, two sat people sat on my hands.
One person sat on top
of me you don't do this
you don't do that you must listen to us
do what we say.
- He slammed me up against the wall,
arm barred me across the throat
and lifted up so I couldn't breathe
and then whispered how am
I supposed to talk to you
nice and slow so you can understand?
- One particular day
we went to see my son,
and we were gonna give him a haircut.
So we took off his
shirt and he was covered
with bruises and abrasions,
15 to 20 on his body, everywhere.
- Yet rest ignored me as I'm locked away
in hidden rooms that pointed
loudly I'm worthless.
I wanted to tell the
agony, but I could not.
(calm music)
- At my old school from
second to seventh grade
I was like an awesome student,
I had great grades I had
perfect attendance awards for
from second grade to seventh
grade for every nine weeks.
I mean I excelled in
history because that is part
of my Asperger's Syndrome.
I have a photographic memory
that's also the reason why
I can't forget what
happened to me in school.
When I was 13 my family
moved seven miles away
to a new school district,
I was being placed in ISS
almost every school day, I
spent 35 consecutive days
in a storage, what used
to be a storage room
under the weight room in
the basement of my school.
It was concrete and
there's two metal doors
that were padlocked from the outside,
there was no windows, and no heat.
And the only person who
had a key to that padlock
was the principal, you
could scream in there
no one would hear you.
Must students did not even know
I was present at school that day.
They'd see me at the end of the day,
getting on the bus and they'd
be like where was you all day?
In the basement.
I remember I was in study skills one time
and I heard my friend in there
and he wasn't allowed out and
he was saying I need to use
the bathroom, I need to use the bathroom
and he defecated and urinated on himself.
And he was he never came
back to school after that.
- So I wanna emphasize that
these aren't isolated incidents
since the department of
education has started collecting
data on the use of restraint
and seclusion in schools
we know that they are tens
of thousands of incidents
around the country
including in California.
And the research that's
been done in California
is we have plenty of it
in the public schools,
but the most frequent use of restraint
and seclusion is in what's
called non public schools.
These aren't private schools
where you pay $40,000
worth of tuition and try
to get your kid in there,
these are schools that
are run by non profits
but are set up solely for the purpose
of taking students with disabilities
that the mainstream school
classroom has decided
don't fit there, and they send them to.
They use public money and send them to
these non public schools.
We have found that
because they're segregated
because many of the students
have limited verbal skills
it is a breeding ground for abuse.
And even, this slide I
should just run through
briefly, which is that
a survey that TASH did
of parents who had kids with
developmental disabilities
found that most of the
kids had been subjected
to restrain and seclusion,
most of them had had
an injury a physical injury,
but virtually all of them
reported emotional trauma.
So even when there aren't broken bones
scrapes, bruises, lacerations
which happen frequently.
The emotional trauma is significant
and really pushes kids out of school,
as she was saying at the
end you know the one kid
who defecated on himself
in seclusion it's very
hard to be going back
to school after that.
So here's what we're
trying to do about it,
in California there's a
school district I won't name
we're still in settlement
discussions with them.
But they had a very high rate of restraint
and seclusion especially in
their segregated classrooms.
When we threatened a lawsuit
with the disability rights
of California and DREDF
they said you know,
no we're trying to do better.
We want to work with you
and so we have been working
with them over the last
year and a half two years.
For a how to improve their practices
and we hope that they will be a model for
how to do a better job of this.
I also want to mention
AB 2657 new legislation
that's been introduced on
California in this part of my talk
I have to report as lobbying
time because it is saying
that we support this legislation.
It is not drastic
legislation it's not banning
the use of restraint and
seclusion but it is installing
the federal guidelines so
that it is only allowed,
when a child or someone
else is in imminent danger
of serious physical injury.
It's not allowed as a form of discipline,
as a form of control, and it is it sets up
procedures if you use
it for how to report,
how to work with the child and the family,
and how to make sure that the
circumstances that brought
about the restraint and
seclusion aren't replicated
so that you don't do it more than once.
We ask of you as health professionals,
I know you're mandatory
reporters, ask about the child's
willingness to go to school
sometimes there aren't
indicators but when there are,
also consider that it may not be because
of falling or family but
because there is abuse at school
and I'd also ask you to
consider supporting AB 2657.
We really need medical
professionals to weigh in,
you have much more weight than lawyers
in talking to the legislature about this.
Okay so shool to prison pipeline
if you're pushed out of
school the chances are likely
that you will be pushed into the prison,
jail, incarceral system.
We know that police and
people with disabilities
don't mix well, people
who have been trained
to command and control
are not really the people
who know how to respond
when people don't react
the way that they expect them to.
People who don't respond
quickly, people who don't behave,
people who don't behave
in the way that their
training has told them
people should behave.
So we know that people with
disabilities get killed
by the police much more
frequently than people
without disabilities we know
that people are incarcerated,
more than half of the people
who are in our prisons
have one disability or another.
Psychiatric disabilities, are the highest
but cognitive disabilities,
developmental disabilities
especially ADHD is also prevalent in five
to six times the rate in
the public population.
So we are advocating for
alternatives to police
in responding to people who are in crisis.
Different police training not additional
but different to reorient
them from the start
and we are fighting against registries,
I don't know if I've heard
of any in California,
but in places around the
country police have been
telling families with
kids who have disabilities
we want you to register your child,
so we know when we go to your household
not to kill him basically
and we don't really like that model.
We think that the police
should take that on themselves
we know that with registries
like this it's generally
wealth white families
that take advantage of it
and that benefit from it.
Okay, so kids with
disabilities are entering the
juvenile justice system
at five times the rate
than other youth in
the general population.
We are working to stem that,
we are working especially
in schools to try and
prevent schools from feeding
the juvenile population
one of the biggest barriers
is what we're all seeing
which is the drive to have
more police in schools
and it's understandable.
But we have been
advocating for I'll explain
what we've been advocating
for, thank you very much.
Police are in schools
not just in high schools
but in middle schools and
in elementary schools.
And what that looks like
is what I'm going to
show you in this next video.
- [Deputy] Here we are.
- [Student] No get off of me stop it!
- I'm going to articulate this for people,
who don't see
- You don't get
to swing at me like that.
- [Student] Get off!
- A Kentucky deputy sheriff
- You don't get to
swing at me like that.
- I still wanna say stop
- Is handcuffing,
- You can do what we've
asked you to,
- an eight year old boy.
- [Deputy] Or you can
suffer the consequences.
- [Student] Ow no that hurts, stop!
- [Deputy] Now sit down in that chair
like I've asked you to.
- [Student] I'm sorry!
(student crying)
- I promise you that I still have not,
I've watched this probably 25 times,
the actual video goes on for 15 minutes
and you would think that
with a video like that
you would take it to the sheriff
and say you've got a rogue
sheriff deputy out here
and you gotta pull him in
and get him some training.
We, our colleagues, our
co-council did that,
the sheriff said absolutely not.
This deputy did exactly
what he was supposed to do,
we found out through discovery
that he had handcuffed
some, between 10 and 15
children in the year that
he'd been doing this work.
That they asserted in their papers,
because of course we sued that these eight
and nine year old kids committing felonies
(audience laughter)
and have doubled down,
this is litigation that's
been going on for two and a half years.
We have gotten a good
judgment from the court
in the sixth circuit
that this was an unlawful
restraint it was excessive force by law
we didn't have to go to court on that.
But they won't settle they
are planning to appeal this
to the supreme court.
So we--
it's pretty bad,
they're furious that we have this video,
it's and the video was
taken by school staff
to show the mother how
difficult the child was being.
(audience laughter)
(audience chatter)
So handcuffing happens around the country,
again another one of
these things that now that
we're collecting we know happens
tens of thousands of times
primarily against kids with disabilities,
especially kids of
color with disabilities.
This trial in Kentucky
we hope will eventually
send a bit of a message we're also working
in Michigan with communities
in Flint to say look
we just don't want police
in elementary schools.
We can have the argument
about how they are
or are not in high schools
but in elementary schools
there's no place for them
and we would like your support there.
And we're also for those
schools where the communities
are divided where some parents feel that
high schools are dangerous
and they want police there.
We're trying to develop
model agreements so that
police are clear that they're
not there to discipline
children that they're only there,
if there's a danger or crime
that they need to intervene on.
Okay 11 minutes left, conservatorships
and supported decision making.
What I usually come and
talk with you about,
so first of all conservatorships
are as most of you know
they are called guardianships
in other parts of the country
are a huge deprivation of an
individual's civil liberties.
It essentially takes legal personhood
away from the individual,
if we're gonna take
that extreme a step a
step that some have called
the most significant
deprivation of civil liberties
aside from the death penalty,
we think you should
have a right to counsel.
So in Utah we are trying out this argument
we don't know if we will
win yet, we'll learn a lot
from the experience and we'll keep trying.
Because we think that anyone
who is being threatened
with conservatorship or guardianship
should have a counsel to
represent their stated interests.
Not what their best interests
are which is what happens
in many states, and in many circumstances,
that's already have someone
else substitute their
decision making for
the individual but have
a counsel represent
their stated interests.
We're also promoting
supported decision-making,
which all of you I think have heard about
a few times now, now that you've got this
under your wing and thank
you we're starting to
work more with our own
kind in the legal system.
Judges so we're working
with the judicial council
to try and help judges
understand what supported
decision-making is to
try and encourage them
to urge that people try
supported decision-making
before imposing a conservatorship.
As the law actually requires,
because in California
you have to use the least
restrictive measure possible.
And we're developing more resources,
the MIND Institute has just
finished a series of videos
and they are available on our website
and the MIND Institute's website.
Okay finally voting, it
seems important to end here
it being the foundation of our democracy.
But 41 states have laws
that disenfranchise people
because of their disability status
and four states have laws
that disenfranchise people
who are idiots, so that is just such a
an opportunity for satire,
of who would qualify.
(laughter)
To be disenfranchised
in those states but is,
just to be clear it is usually enforced
against people with
developmental disabilities.
So in California almost
everyone who is put under
a conservatorship also automatically lost
their right to vote, the
solution was to amend
the California electoral code
and the standard that
the disability community
has come up with which I think
is just a superb standard
is that anyone who
expresses a desire to vote
with or without accommodations
should be able to vote.
So whether the expression
needs an accommodation
or being able to vote
needs an accommodation,
that's the criteria we need to use.
So the law has been updated
thanks to my colleague
Claudia Center and we just
need to get the word out.
Our affiliates have been
doing that but to the extent
that you can, we would like your help.
Also online voter
registration huge benefit
to the disability community,
you don't have to go down
fill out a form by hand,
make sure that they've got it
right because the forms
that are filled out by hand
are then translated and typed by people
who can't necessarily read your writing.
But for people who need
assistive technology,
to use websites almost all of the websites
that were completed are inaccessible.
So we did a report showing what
the most common errors were
sent it to all the secretaries of states,
have been encouraging people to update
their websites we're making progress
and in New York we decided to sue,
the wrong state to sue and we
knew that they actually fight
every lawsuit tooth and nail
but we didn't want to seem
partisan and they're a democratic state.
So that's where we sued, and
they have already improved
their website quite a bit
and we are in settlement
negotiations there.
I would encourage you, I
know you are not one of the
offices that is required by the
national voter registration
act to help your clients
come in to register to vote,
but if you can, if you have
the time ask them if they're
interested in voting, let
them know that they can
register online and please
let us know if you hear
of any problems.
We want to make sure that
this system is working
even in California where we assume
and think most things
are going well California
was the only state that the website
was accessible to start with.
Okay so,
the Statue of Liberty is
the symbol for the ACLU
and for the country, and I use
her to just begin my thanks.
I'm really appreciative
of this the Shriver Award
we knowledge that it's
not just to recognize
the little bit of work that the new
disability rights project,
that the ACLU is doing
but really the work that
my colleagues at the ACLU
are doing and the community is doing.
To fight this, incredible
stress test to our democracy.
(laughter)
So I want to thank you
for all of your work,
and I've be happy to answer questions.
(applause)